hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tara just saw tonight I
wouldn't saw hereditary quote Doug
Walker about this film it's stuck with
me and it really got into like my bones
and pits Oh y'all it's so good there
won't be any major spoilers in this
episode I don't think I don't know I
might mind is reeling from this film so
I might just start babbling on but
nothing cry won't like you know reveal
names or anything crazy like that
hereditary is about a family the mom is
a artist she makes miniatures the dad is
just trying to do is very best frankly
and the son and daughter are in school
and it is just a tragedy a tragedy
unfolding upon this family in a way
that's told so well and the stories that
while you're watching it at some point
you're like is this what's happening or
is this what's happening I can't I am oh
I definitely need to see it again
immediately but it takes a moment for
you to like fully visualize what's
happening and and really until the very
end it honestly has some really great
points of it that reminded me a lot of
Hamill said it comes at night not what I
wanted to say the which the vinovich and
the Baba duck both movies that I had
that had some really wonderful aspects
of horror that I really enjoyed this
took those kind of aspects and just like
pumped it up and it was like horrifying
and terrifying and like oh my god just
on freakin comfortable I will say I
walked into the theater tonight at 7
o'clock first showing at the theater I
go to in Chicago and it was packed i sat
up in the second row so the first and
second rows were the only ones that had
seats open and unfortunately when the
trailer started this annoying noise
happened was it wouldn't stop and he
went throughout the
tire movie it was just like this
like really loudly so some of the softer
dialogue I actually did it here pulley
because of this insane noise and and a
lot of people in the first ten minutes
really shuffling out leaving I think the
theater was giving them refunds but I
was seeing this for work I couldn't go
to a later showing you have to go super
early so I sat through it but at the end
I got up and I turned around and there
was only one other couple in the very
back that had stayed for the whole thing
and but even through all of that all of
the terrible audio issues that the
theater was having for this screening
the sound design was incredible it was
so so so crucial to the suspense of this
film and the scares and the scares were
so well executed it wasn't like this
like scary like whoa gotcha
like a jump scare it was very much it's
like a wide-open shot and the scary
thing is just in front of you and you're
just like oh they're just showing it to
me like they're just gonna do that to me
yes they are so we all know I don't know
that what should help no but I felt like
my like inner filmmaker was coming out
like it just is so beautifully done
in a way that's accessible to someone
like me who doesn't know that much about
film the shots were beautiful and
unnerving no I looked at what this
director had done before and it wasn't
anything that I knew which you know it's
not saying much but like nothing crazy
big holy moley there I maybe better give
this so many more projects after this I
was talking to Doug Walker about this
movie before I saw it he didn't spoil
anything for me he just said the family
dynamics are scarier than like the
actual scares and I super agree with
that because you kind of place yourself
in this in my notes I wrote like I
thought I had like no trouble family in
some areas it really puts with
everyone's family to shame watching this
and I think you put yourself in their
shoes you see that that's a possibility
you see that think that could be me I
could that could happen at some point
you know and it's whore
fine like the words that they use
against each other and the hurt that
they caused each other it's it's it gets
you it gets you real good one thing I
really liked about the the shops and the
cinematography is the the mom who I
don't know her name she's out of this
world so good Toni Collette Tomi you're
so good Toni Collette oh my god she's
like my favorite actress now this was an
insane performance that she had to give
where she's teetering the lines of a
mental breakdown and like has she gone
insane or are the things that she thinks
are happening are they happening what
what is what is going on and she never
goes over the top in the way that it's
like unbelievable
it's very over-the-top but it's not like
you know a slap in the face it's not
like oh my gosh
yeah I'm ridiculous it's so well done
and so boiled over and just oh man she's
so good and her her character makes
miniatures in these little rooms in
these little houses and the movie opens
on a miniature of their own house you
slowly go into the son's room kinda
looks like there's something over his
bed it's not over his bed it's like an
illusion thing and throughout the whole
movie you get this big shot like six or
seven times you get a shot of outside of
their home it's a very secluded home out
in the middle of nowhere a bunch of big
trees every time you get this big shot
it looks just like a miniature and by
the end of the movie they start turning
the lights on and off for morning and
night and it's like okay what shots are
miniatures what shots aren't it's really
really well done it's very like Wes
Anderson horror I also really loved how
they did the lighting at night there's a
lot of night scenes that took place in
the house and the house is really dark
but outside is super well-lit it kind of
seems like it's like 7:00 a.m. like the
Sun is out but it's just like a little
gloomy you know what I mean there is a
lot of spiritual nough supernatural
elements in this but it doesn't overtake
the family stuff going on or doesn't
over
the story and it doesn't make it cheesy
there's like something I would have been
watching a scene for like a full two
minutes and the whole time there was
like something in the corner and I like
noticed it two minutes in it's like oh
my god that's smoke terrified you were
there the whole time weren't you you
were I know you were your work you're
tricky how many of those did I miss cuz
it happened quite a few times I said
this earlier but like the scaring where
it's just like they put it out in front
of you it's not like around the corner
and something grabs at you there's a
couple like fast sequences that are
scary but mostly it's just like right in
front of your eyes the whole time and I
really loved that there is one effect a
supernatural entity effect that they use
that I don't love but he did take me out
of it it just was something that didn't
like blow me away I also wonder because
babadook became like such an LGBT anthem
[Laughter]
because the little girl does the whole
like mouth thing and that's it like it's
a very big drag queen thing so I wonder
I'm here for it I hope it does I've so
many questions about it I can't wait to
read theories on this like with the
babadook you know there was all these
people like oh my gosh you know the
monsters like anxiety and oppression and
like all this stuff and I you know spent
hours just reading through all these
theories I love horror films for that
and this is gonna have so many I think I
also think after you watch the whole
thing completely a lot of those
questions are answered for you but in a
very vague way in a way you want them to
be answered but in a way that's like you
know people people are still gonna be
writing some theories out of there's one
moment in the middle of the film before
you figure out what's happening where it
feels a little disjointed it feels like
is this what I thought it was initially
what they were like hinting at initially
or is it this completely new thing which
one is it and then at the end it all
comes together and I also think a second
watching is really gonna help with that
but there is a like like a
you know 20 minutes were you like it was
the first or the second thing cuz I just
can't tell they did a really good job
bringing it together I didn't hate the
end I know a lot of horror films I just
have terrible terrible endings and I
really enjoyed this one whose very
unsettling oh my god I mean I don't
think I'll ever I this is this my
favorite horror film I think it might be
and the end has a lot of naked old men
and also I start tons of naked people
and I'm never sleeping again so you up
for an all-nighter Ike he's not he's
over there sleeping
[Music]
babadook babadook babadook